hello everybody I hope you didn't mind
the whole thing that happened in the
last episode so here we go we're gonna
get it oh are you so slow No
[ __ ] you [ __ ] I think girl yours janky
hope I shut up yeah ramble around I
ramble around with you all the time
water David oh sure I will baby I'll
come visit you all the time she knows
she knows so much indeed I'm sorry I was
busy you know with although I
investigative and work and other as like
doing is f who do you're not my booty
call who the hell are you it was a piece
of cake Patrick said it will be easier
for you to visit her here now about that
he was finally revealing his true
intentions woohoo
okay so there is a lot more hmm
doc just selwyn I have been unable to
organize my sessions given the state of
our study three years inpatient
suffering severely from differentl
disease should be constantly and watch
and my weekly sessions without a patient
prevent million to advance further in my
study about the memory replacement you
know the importance of my study and the
possible outcomes to open an era in this
field and possible cures therefore if
you please I'd like to dismiss all the
sessions except graces and Sophia's
until we reach a state but conduct
physical experiment those two are really
important for any deferred and my study
I'd like to spend more time about their
conditions another thing is for you to
consider that those two have become good
friends which is surprising an
interesting situation considering Sophia
never had or wanted friends and she came
here I'd like to examine the friendship
and its effect on their connection dr. P
V he hid dr. P B hey okay
I am the equivalent of a twelve year old
little boy okay hey I have the humor of
a child
how is she Patrick Oh doing horribly
wait am I where the hell where the
helmet wait wait huh
wait that's just one big ass hallway but
is that the only way to go mmm
how sure species problem Oh dumb ass
boyfriend
come on burger burger Brora pick that
that one can leave that one can stay
I don't mind on and out and a women I
need to confront sternly Sofia you hear
you gusto fear there's no cylinder in
the phonograph why is there a phonograph
here I've been thinking about that
artistic feeling might be able to reach
different parts of the Mayas we came out
Ridgway morelia can vannacutt and unused
or worse misused part of the brain does
four or five the results of regular
sessions is just a theory but visions
I'm attending seemed interested in the
music experiments although I cannot
exploit a little a little time to buy
stereo okay ah blah blah blah blah
there's a lot of reading to do and none
of time to read it in okay so good dude
rock rock girl well okay so what's this
ooh does this actually have oh-oh sugars
you get you get your good no it's a lie
the lightbulb is a lie a dirty dirty lie
ooh
hi hi how are you I'm great thank you
thank you you're feeling much better
today oh yes doctor
she's Scottish oh yeah okay okay I'm
perfectly fine yeah oh yeah I oh hi so
then he don't find it boring I can't
visit lady Di's what do you expect for
me okay
so that's all of that I'm wondering if
just all of these rooms up here just be
so blind she was in front of my eyes all
the time who who was okay
okay okay whatever whatever here we go
what am I doing with all this stuff
oh okay alright that was it I guess huh
what is the point of all this what is
the point what is going on okay that
one's like I'm going downstairs screw
this screw all this anything like open
up or weight was buy that painting huh
nothing okay so nothing happened exactly
nothing
yep epic leap uh what did up parkour at
the invisible walls okay
ha I'm visible wall why why can't I jump
from the stairs don't want me to kill
myself uh I must be being incepted this
doesn't look good okay that was a locked
door anyway so it didn't even need to
look good come on let's get something
going let's get something gone nah come
on what the [ __ ] pepper what the [ __ ]
is it certain mm well what the hell do I
miss something upstairs
did I out table dumb don't push me
around
don't push me around table I'm on I'm on
the edge III III III I can't handle how
this alright so basically what this game
is telling me is to go screw myself with
a rusty shovel if I'm getting that
correctly hmm does it have to be rusty
oh the rusty or the better oh well thank
you game I'll take that into
consideration
all right so apparently I've been in
there I've been in there I've looked
over here did I get why is that table
keep pushing me away
why won't anything let me get close to
it I just want to be loved
okay
those don't even open that and this
disband way was there something under
there nope uh-uh nope there had to be
something with the phonograph and
something of import about that wait a
minute maybe while it was playing
something opened up hang on wait a tick
yeah darah blah okay so it's playing
ergo well I'm everywhere today no I was
thinking like why was playing dudududu
okay so what is the Olo what's going on
here whoo-hoo hello I can play and the
violin Oh L violin Oh as it's known as
is in its native country treated a
little I know okay so that's a negative
hang on wait hang on why aren't you
playing with that what the hell oh come
on
okay so this
is it a music bottle puzzle not puddle
Oh what the hell
what is this measure I don't even I was
like three beats
you don't make any sense you damn pianer
what do I do with you what always what
to do this phonograph broke bra stupid
phonograph hole - turn it girl
golly Germany Christmas what the hell do
I do
jiminy Christmas
okay so I have no idea I've got no damn
clue what I'm supposed to do I've got
absolutely no idea what not what no hell
what am i uh what am i uh what am I
doing here
ah what am i ah what am I doing here
ah alright I've got no clue I've kind of
just been wandering the same place for a
while now I would love to be able to
progress for you guys out there but
apparently I'm too stupid to figure it
out
is it like some note that I got I don't
think I've get music maybe was something
in here hmm
ah I'll try to make them play the tune
with the piano exactly from the they
listen to the phonograph okay so it is
like I have to recite from the
phonograph er
done
that's the end that's the middle that's
the repeat okay so
dun dun dun dun dun
wasn't that it I don't know oh no this
is broked this be brooked who broke my
sonogram
who broke it alright so apparently since
I'm a giant idiot I don't gonna end it
here cuz I said it's just gonna be back
you're like a giant fool unless you want
to do that ha ha ha fly man boo it is me
me me me shall real good if I head on
randomly I'll get it eventually just
like all of these puzzle hey bubbles
I'm so bad I'm okay so someone treat me
like I'm two years old and write
exquisitely explicitly what I'm posed to
do with the comments like dad dinner 1 6
2 4 9 or whatever what have you and then
I'll figure this out later so thank you
all so much for watching sorry for
cutting it early but hopefully I'll get
it done in the next one so thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
ooh Oh it's time Oh tis time tomorrow
hahaha
bring it [ __ ] bring it [ __ ] oh
what's that you wanna live too bad
hahaha another one that's wrong I am the
greatest forever one